so let me see if I can find this this
story that we've got a couple stories
but this is the one I really want to get
to the new trend this young people who
have no regard for I don't know
existence they're basically a whole
bunch of little jokers out of control
teenagers coughing on grocery store
produce let me first say something this
may surprise many of you but I'm gonna
have some defensive words for
Millennials often I like to rag on
Millennials for being stunted you know
lackadaisical layabouts on Millennials
are a little older now they're not the
teens that are stupid sadly so we're now
we're complaining about these young uns
now so just happening because you know
the same thing with bite you for Gen X
when they were younger because
millennial was the go-to like rep
scallion with no regard for whatever
okay boomer it's the same thing right
yeah well no no that's going that's
going up right it's the other way
you know they dragged Millennials for
all of the things that Gen Z is doing
mmm-hmm Millennials are nearing 40 you
know in their mid-30s now you have
houses in the suburbs and kids and kids
what they are not the ones going around
planking partying in in South Beach
during a pandemic they're the ones on
the balconies screaming go home yeah
we're getting old
yeah we're getting real cranky and now
we'll cranky and these pepper snappers
often on produce
I never knew about that yeah I don't
know if I believe it yeah yeah they say
pour it down the crack and then catch it
under the brush and they do it's like a
human sentence or what they're putting
their mouth of the time yep dude they're
they're going under the butts I just why
have you emulate have you been to South
Beach bro no a party and I will never go
well yeah cuz you're an old man no wait
okay then go to South Beach actually
that well that's right we did we walked
through and we're like look at all these
crazy people I have only two words fibra
okay boomer oh sure and now I'm
officially a boomer and a millennial
okay somehow idle teenagers are
participating
disturbing trend of coughing on grocery
store produce and posting their pranks
online as the nation fights the
coronavirus which is known to spread
from human droplets sprang from mouths
the latest incident occurred in the
Washington Xserve of Percival Virginia
some 5555 miles from the White House
according to a Percival Police
Department report an incident occurred
at a local grocery store involving
juveniles reportedly coughing on produce
while filming themselves and posting it
on social media congratulations young
people you are dumb yeah the report said
that the store identified on social
media as Harris Teeter immediately
removed the items and cleaned up the
area the police said the grocery store
immediately removed the items in
question and has taken appropriate
measures to ensure the health of store
patrons on a community Facebook page one
woman who said she witnessed the event
wrote Punk teenagers are hitting the
grocery stores coughing all over the
produce and the grocery items filming it
and posting it to YouTube it scared the
hell out of one elderly woman who was
just trying to grocery shop why the hell
aren't these people keeping their teens
home this is not summer vacay the police
investigating the case said there is a
national trend by teenagers to cough on
food and film it that sounds right this
is it does it's right we are at it it's
not even surprising ways a quote we are
asking for parental assistance in
monitoring your teenagers activities as
well as their social media posts to
avoid the increase of any further - such
incidents we have learned that this
appears to be disturbing trend on social
media across the country and we ask for
help from parents discourage this
behavior immediately in the past two
weeks schools around the nation have
closed as authorities deal with the
virus and go back go back so this quote
here when they're saying we're asking
for parental assistance it's like no no
no don't assist be parents we are to
your kids job do your job you have kids
it's your responsibility to teach them
that this is stupid this pisses me off
so there's a so Argent argentina's on
lockdown stupid people and there was a
video on reddit of a bunch of Gen Z
people like hang out in the park mm-hmm
and then cops show up in hazmat suit
start running full-speed and like
tackling them and arresting them and
I've mixed him I have mixed feelings
about this okay like I'm like I'm not
sure I'm a fan of like the government
coming in and cracking down on people
stand around
yeah but I'm also extremely annoyed by
these ridiculously arrogant morons yeah
poor like who cares Twitterverse trying
to get likes i can't get hurt oh yeah
coughing on yeah yeah you're yeah oke
and it's dude sore and face the brunt
it's like these little kids know they're
out of school they have nothing to do
yeah so they're doing what social media
has bred them to do yeah that's true and
be stupid because it gets them clicks
you gotta stop glorifying this stuff
it's not even about glorifying it it's
about they do though it during the news
boom everyone sit they want it's not
even a glorified oh it's great this is
the first time we've done this or talked
about something like this and I don't
see their names I don't see their
pictures I don't I don't see the the
videos of them coughing awesome this is
great is this is just exactly what
needed to happen like parents need to
know that this is the case stop it from
doing it here's the phone here's the
thing like this is over-the-top
agreed but even the kids the I shouldn't
even say the kids they're like 20 or
older no buts those teenagers no but I'm
talking about the South Beach stuff oh
so like these are these are you know
older college students drinking yeah we
are getting these mandatory lockdowns
now because of that in New Jersey they
put the curfew in place because the
governor straight-up said there are too
many videos of these young people going
to bars and just not caring so now we're
gonna shut the bars down yeah so you
mean to tell me I can't responsibly you
know go about my business maybe have a
drink because a bunch of dumb kids are
sharing drinks and partying and sipping
booze iphitos butts I mean I'm pretty
sure we're at the point where you know
that it's much easier and better to just
go spend the same amount you at the bar
for like five times the amount of liquor
right now and bring it home and bring
all your friends home but here hang out
here so you know what Manzi we're in the
suburbs you have a backyard yeah dude I
did were lucky I do not envy city fault
man I I'm grateful for that skate ramp
dude I'll skating out there and it's
it's awesome I don't know what I would
do without you so I'm seeing all these
posts where people are talking about
exercises you can do at home yeah I know
because they're people who live in
cubicles in New York yeah and they spend
most their time outside of their cubicle
that you sleep in it but I can't well
there's this whole skate thing going
around where
people are doing in ski tricks inside
it's kind of cool actually
actually one kid did a trick and I saw
the floor break I was like oh I don't
think he even noticed
I saw one cool thing we're cool they're
rocking out some killer tricks a dude
using just the deck with no wheels is
the cool stuff done actually with the
cow and the cow chopping up on the couch
yeah I do I was so tempted my mother
ouch and then did like a kickflip off of
it it did a few tricks that's cool check
it out man skateboarders are doing cool
stuff yeah they're they're not going out
and causing problems right they're not
drinking that coffee not drinking
produce here's the thing you know it is
hmm skateboarders have an outlet for
doing something on camera to get likes
that's a good point
Thanks yeah The Tribune yeah these
people don't have that so they fill that
gap with nonsense like coughing on
people's you know on produce and stores
and yeah that's crazy man true you know
I think I think that might be why I
never grew up actually look when I was
younger we did dumb stuff yeah we but we
wouldn't go into a store and coughin
people's produce like this we would go
out and skate and we would other things
like I guess I grew up in the in the in
the Bam Margera CKY kind of era okay so
so I've heard in your friends and
yourself more than but it was consensual
others right it was a consensual sensual
hurt like getting in a shopping cart and
having crashed into a curb and you go
flying out of it roll in the grass yeah
or into a bush everybody seemed to love
doing that
I was admit I've done it myself I was
more into the skateboarding though right
yeah so what we were doing was stupid
kid stuff but skateboarding quickly
became that outlet where was like if you
wanted a really likes back then I guess
you know we still had video views and
stuff in the early days of social media
but if you want to get attention and you
wanted to show off you had to be good at
skateboarding yeah it's not really so
even the kids I knew who didn't like
skateboarding would still try and do
something to be like look I can do
something too now you've got kids grow
up without anything but social media is
making it so well they want followers
that's like the thing to be successful
these days how many followers do you
have only likes you have how many
because you get right well they found a
way mm-hmm so it's it's it's like the
the dude who got arrested for licking
the ice cream yeah it's it's going to
keep getting worse and now that we're in
a national emergency I wouldn't be
surprised if we're going to see this
1010
this tenfold I agree because I mean even
the celebrities are going crazy oh right
rich ass places so what about spurt
froda bachchan yeah death they're
desperate for my ad let alone like the
kids that you know they're actually
getting attention when they go to school
you know they're around with their peers
other kids like you know that there
still is that aspect so they're getting
some sort of something from it but now
that they have nothing you know they
gotta stay inside their homes it's just
gonna be like like the internet was a
mistake I'm kidding and it's awesome
yeah that's great but in some ways it
really magnifies all our flaws well the
bigger problem is bad parenting yeah
there we're asking parents for
assistance here no it's it's called
telling the parents to do their jobs as
parents smell kid
I'm kidding don't smack them what I'm
being fair exactly I'm not a parent I'm
not a parent either help to raise so
many kids in my life because I have
younger siblings younger cousins for
days I've got younger cousins and there
was always a baby around always and it
was always pitched off to like the
teenagers of the family which happened
to me me for a while and then I don't
know this is if this is just like the
hard times make strong men you know so
we've we've we've got parents in it's a
bubble so they keep trying to be the
cool parents I'm cool I'm hip I'm with
it oh and then yeah do what you want
kids that was really funny right as when
the kids are out of control
yeah they do dumb stuff and of course
that all of Jen's II don't want to
offend anyone yup especially their kid
oh that yeah yeah do you see speaking of
the coronavirus right Colbert he built
his career of offensive comedy yeah
mocking different races and stereotypes
and he defended it by saying my
character made those jokes right now now
that he's on CBS he's just gonna say
he's letting go of this character and
now he's gonna be himself he said that
when he started right the point is I
don't dude just because he's doing a
character he's making offensive jokes he
was making fun he had a routine
he would make fun of Asians hmm and then
every time he got called out and they
would attack him for it he would double
down yeah and it was hilarious run we
all respected it yeah like you go man
it's a joke grow up mm-hmm
now that he left they went to CBS now
he's completely in agreement with all of
these like can't make you know nasty
jokes or whatever that's a shame
yep so it's it's the the desperation to
fit in and the evolution of the the
people who are supposed to be cool will
say whatever you have to say so when
these kids are out of control and say
whatever they want the parents go you
got it
whatever you say mm-hmm they become
losers they become become weak thanks
for checking out this segment from the
Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
every Monday through Friday at 8 p.m.
sometimes an hour or two and we do have
a full live recorded version of the show
that includes a lot of comments and
smaller segments you probably don't see
if you want to check that out you can
watch live at 8 p.m. Monday through
Friday or become a member of this
channel and for five bucks a month you
get full access to all of the recorded
podcasts every day after the show we
make them available in the community
section of this YouTube channel so don't
forget to subscribe and stick around for
more segments and more shows Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m.
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all in the next show
you